don't get much shine they're playing  with their brother i think they want to  introduce the world to who they are  i would root for them i'm going with him  tonight but i'm going with team rookie  i'm going with team cavs  i'm going for the guys playing in front  of the home folks i think they've been  doing it too much that man right there  got the best job security in the history  of civilization right there who's that  scottie boss john is on to comupo  as long as as long as his brother is the  man he gonna have a job  he's gonna have a job he's not a bad  player i know i didn't say he was a bad  player but i'm saying they know they're  not job security they got for job  security that boy gonna always have a  job as long as his brother's the man  so this is about the only thing you  haven't done on all-star saturday night  would be uh would be a skills what about  what about when yeah  it's saturday night i got money in the  bank from